In the past week, two
reports have underscored
just how widespread the threat o
bands has become.
One by pen
America says that
book bans in public schools
during the most recently complet
year were up 33%.
More than 40% of all book bans,
according to the Penn report,
occurred in Florida school distr
And that state's governor,
presidential candidate Ron DeSan
as you know, championed a law in
that requires approval of books
and school libraries.
Now, a separate report
by the American Library Associat
says that almost half of book ch
occurring through
August have occurred in public l
Last week, more than 175 writers
and actors
and entertainers
and others signed a letter warni
how these bands are, quote,
antithetical to free speech
and expression,
how they'll have a, quote,
chilling effect
on the broader creative field.
My next guest signed that letter
Amanda Gorman.
She's a poet and author
who famously read one of her poe
at President Biden's inauguratio
She's also the author of her
new children's book out Tomorrow
Something Someday
I want to talk to
you about your new book,
your children's book.
But I want to talk
first about
that book, Banning,
which you and I have talked abou
Pen America,
the literary group
which you've partnered with in t
They say that there's a 33%
increase in book bans
during the last school year.
You experienced this with your b
The Hill
We Climb is restricted
in the Florida school district.
Where is this?
Where does this go?
I think
the book bans will continue to r
unless they meet some type of im
as you mentioned.
I think it's really important
to put it in numbers as well.
These are thousands of book bans
We've seen over 3000 this year.
But you also have to look at it
from the point of view.
Last year,
60% of those thousand
were pretty much filed by 11 peo
So this is an incredibly small
but vocal and coordinated minori
The book that was restricting
the Hill We Climb was
was kind of an offshoot of your
which you write
at the inauguration of President
I just want to play an excerpt o
because for so many people, it's
the first time they ever saw you
So let's just watch it.
We are striving to forge a union
with purpose, to compose
a country
committed to all cultures, color
characters, and conditions of ma
It gave so much sense of hope
and sort of optimism.
Do you still feel that sense of
100% for me.
Hope isn't a gift we possess.
It's a gift that we practice.
It's something that
we have to fight for
and to learn and grow and lean i
So I wake up every day fighting
not just for justice,
but for my own hope and
keeping that flame alive. I'm
writing a children's book.
What is the process?
How do you go about it?
Yeah, I'm
sure you've noticed this
reading children's books to your
but they're actually really comp
and sophisticated.
They really are.
You really are.
And so you have to write it at a
that's accessible for the young
but also an enjoyable experience
for the parent,
for the family, for the guardian
And so I always try to start
with the heart of the book.
I was thinking
was the experience
of being a caregiver, caretaker
of a young child
at this time who has big questio
about the world.
That's the other thing
that children's books,
which I hadn't know much about
until I did this, is, you know,
it's talking about
what's on the page with your chi
that's so interesting
and the meaning of the words
and what they see in the images
and things that they didn't see
they suddenly see. Absolutely.
And I think
that's why
poetic thought lends itself
so well to storytelling.
Especially with young children,
because you're looking
at the unit of language
as the most powerful measurement
of sound and literature.
So for me,
writing a few words on a page
isn't a prison.
It's a privilege.
And so getting to think very fin
what's the word
that's going to have the most im
on this beautiful, gorgeous soul
that's reading my words.
That's the fundamental question
of poetry.
The sound of the words matter to
they may in poetry.
Absolutely.
And I think that comes
from my background.
Having a speech impediment,
being able to read
poetry out
loud was a huge form of my own s
therapy and pathology.
And so I look at it on the page
how does this feel kind of movin
through a young person's,
like body and mouth?
And is this something I could im
someone saying aloud as a huge c
Is that something
you still struggle with?
Because I had a reading issue
when I was a child of mild
form of dyslexia.
And I went to somebody
and I also sort of stuttered
and still do occasionally
Is that something you struggle w
100%?
I mean, it's something
I think a lot of people use the
like overcome the speech impedim
I'm like, no,
the speech impediment is coming
wherever I'm going,
but I'm just carrying it
in a different way.
And so after,
you know, around
20 years of speech therapy,
I can have this conversation wit
But even just now,
I was saying the word like priso
and saying that R was hard for m
because that's what I struggle
the most with.
And so you push through
and I focus more on the content
of what I'm saying than how
it sounds sort of peers.
And I think that's
what gives me the bravery
to continue what I do.
What is the idea behind this boo
Something someday.
What did you want it?
The message to be to a child Yea
Well, you know,
I was thinking
because I meet
with so many young children,
especially in elementary school
and middle school,
and they are incredibly
emotionally intelligent.
They know there's disruptions
and transformations
happening in the world,
and they really want to understa
what third place is within it,
even from a very young age.
And I wanted to write a book
that safeguarded and preserves t
and their power and their spirit
and their vibrancy.
And doing that kind of
in the legacy of the songs I lov
just this idea of change going t
I don't know when it's going to
I can't tell you
if it's tomorrow or the next day
or what it's going to look like.
But I know it's arriving soon, s
because of the young people
we have in the world right now.
Would you read something? Absolu
So I'm going to read just a smal
excerpt from the middle book
you make a promise to each other
You say there is a problem,
but it's our problem together
so we can fix it together.
This problem is big, but togethe
we are bigger.
It's lovely to hear something so
Yes. Thank you so much.
Thank you for having me.
Amanda Gorman's new book,
Something Someday Comes Out Tomo